how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder and today we have some pretty big
news about a show that we perhaps know
the least about in the entirety of
marvel's phase 4 slate
actually we're kind of not even sure if
it's in phase 4 at this point in time
but we're talking about
she-hulk it seems like marvel studios is
getting pretty close to back to normal
or as normal as they can get considering
the fact that we're in a pandemic right
now
but the falcon and the winter soldier
has resumed production the one division
series is said to go back
really soon the set for the loki series
is being built
right now as we speak and pre-production
has started for the she-hulk
series so we'll break down this new
report and talk about everything that we
currently know about this mysterious
she-hulk series coming to disney plus if
you're new to the channel and you love
marvel be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest mcu
updates
and this week's giveaway is a thanos
funko pop all you have to do to enter
subscribe like the video leave a comment
down below
so as i mentioned marvel studios is
getting the ball rolling with the
she-hulk series
we have two big reports today and the
first one is that the she-hulk series is
going to begin production
very soon in fact they're going to begin
production on the she-hulk series in
february of 2021 and this report is
coming from thedirect.com
their sources have told them that the
she-hulk series is going to be filming
in atlanta georgia
after the other disney plus series get
done filming mainly the falcon and the
winter soldier and the one division
series depending on where marvel studios
decides to pick up filming again for
that show so since production is going
to start pretty soon that means we
should be getting some casting
information about the show relatively
soon as well
especially if we consider the second big
news that we got today
the she-hulk series now has a director
it appears that kat
koiro is heading to the marvel cinematic
universe in a report yesterday from
deadline they said that
cat coiro is now headed to the mcu and
is in negotiations to direct the pilot
and several other episodes of marvel
she-hulk they also said that she is
going to come on board as an executive
producer as well
so we have a director we have a
production date the next thing that
comes
is the casting itself of she-hulk
jennifer walters now the last we heard
from marvel insider daniel richmond is
that marvel studios is eyeing a
allison bree type for the role of
jennifer walters
she hulk and i personally loved this
because i thought she was really great
on community
which the russo brothers happened to
direct so she has a direct
connection to marvel studios through the
russo brothers who of course are super
tight with marvel studios having
directed captain
america the winter soldier where they
just so happened to give danny putty a
cameo in and he was a co-star of allison
bree on community so the russo brothers
have already done this with marvel
studios before so it seems like alison
brie is a shoe-in to play she-hulk so
we'll have to wait for an official
confirmation on that however there are
some things that we do know
jennifer walters is the cousin of bruce
banner and he's partly the reason that
she becomes she-hulk jennifer walters
gets into an
accident and in order to save her life
bruce banner does a blood transfusion
he does save her life but then she ends
up transforming into
she-hulk and mark ruffalo has already
commented that yes he will appear
in the she-hulk series if kevin feige
asks him to and there's a story for it
well there is a story for it considering
bruce banner is the reason jennifer
walters becomes
she-hulk but you do kind of gotta give
it up to mark ruffalo for at least
trying not to give away spoilers
and lastly we do know that the writers
for the show have indeed finished the
script
so things are well underway for the
she-hulk series and it looks like marvel
studios is going to be starting
production
very soon in february of 2021.
who do you want to see play she-hulk
slash jennifer walters in the mcu in the
she-hulk series and what do you want
from this series be sure to let me know
your thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest
mcu news for live updates and other
funko pop giveaways you can follow me on
twitter and
instagram and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof